move now into another dimension fessor
lanes gary from harvard or through the
monarchy you haven't been pushing them
books for all our speakers workbooks so
there's a quotation that I very much
like from Gandhi that says you can wake
a man who's asleep but you can't wake a
man who's pretending to be asleep and I
don't know whether the American
population is actually asleep or
pretending to be asleep but it is very
hard to get people aware of this and I
think that Allen robux work on nuclear
winter showing that if only one
one-hundredth of 1% of the current
Arsenal's used billions of people will
die within the first month has done a
great deal to wake people up whoever
actually looks at his research does
begin to see the problem we know from
Hiroshima and Nagasaki that what the
devastating physical effects are of even
a small atomic weapon and the physicians
for Social Responsibility and Alan
robock and his colleagues working on
nuclear winter make it very clear that
millions of people in the in the world
as well as millions of birds and animals
and plants will be devastated if there
should be even a small exchange of
nuclear weapons and my work is trying to
show that in addition to this incredible
physical injury there's also a profound
Civic injury that has occurred by the
existence of nuclear weapons Alan showed
you the the graph for 2014 this is the
graph for 2015 it's almost the same
there are a few there's a tiny number of
scheduled to be retired weapons that
have been retired but there are also
ominous things coming up China for the
first time has a an accomplished ssbn
nuclear submarine force that's now on
the ground for the first time and as he
said close to ninety four percent of the
weapons are owned by Russia which is
everything from the blackout on your
left
outside and the United States which is
everything from the blackout on the
right hand side and we know that this
has put the earth in peril as The
Bulletin of Atomic Scientists has said
for the last two years where we've now
got a three-minute warning in which we
can act and still have blue sky the
civic injury comes about from what is
obvious from what irony and Allen have
just said there is no way to protect
yourself against this Arsenal so it has
eliminated from all human beings on
earth the right of self-defense this may
seem like a small point but the right of
self-defense is a right underlying every
other right that we have and the right
of self-defense is also at the
foundation of the human capacity for
governance I should say here that in
addition to eliminating the right of
self-defense it's eliminated as iris
talk made clear has eliminated our
capacity for mutual aid there is no way
to help each other if there are only 94
beds in a terrain that will include tens
of thousands of burn injuries now given
the incredible incredible physical
impact of these weapons why would we
even stopped to talk about the fact to
say PS its destroyed governance I think
there are three reasons why it's crucial
to hold on to this first is that this
isn't a additional effect it's what
we're looking at when we look at this
gigantic architecture that has no
purpose other than annihilation that is
that architecture of state weaponry does
not exist for some other purpose that
incidentally entails the possibility of
annihilation it exists in order to bring
about that harm that has been brought
about by jettisoning various
governmental components that had they
been followed would have made nuclear
weapons impossible now try in the short
time I have to begin to show
you how that's true second of all even
if it were possible that we didn't have
an exchange of nuclear weapons or a
single use of nuclear weapons and that's
nearly impossible as earlier speakers
today I've said and as Max continually
points out the chances that this isn't
going to happen are you know close to
zero possibly zero but even if it didn't
happen the desecration to civic society
is already happening and it's happening
right now the fact that people don't
have any voice don't have any right of
self-defense aren't seen as having the
stature that would let them address the
problem of their own defense is a
terrible thing and then third of all
rights I think in this room this is most
important understanding that governance
provides the tools for dismantling the
nuclear arsenal is crucial just because
it's among the things we have at our
disposal for undoing the current
situation that we have the the various
constitutional national and
international legal instruments had to
be put aside in order to have nuclear
weapons because you can't have nuclear
weapons and be following these laws so
we just jettison the laws but if we
bring back those laws we can only bring
them back by jettisoning the nuclear
weapons and so the to the fact that the
two are mutually exclusive is a very
important detail of them the fact that
that the human beings on earth have lost
the right of self-defense is shown by
the fact that we don't even hear voices
around the world asking us to eliminate
our huge arsenal when I showed you that
graph a moment ago and the huge number
of weapons owned by the United States
you can see that when we hear about
nuclear weapons in this country we hear
about Iran which isn't on that graph
doesn't have nuclear weapons Iraq
doesn't have nuclear weapons we hear
about North Korea it
under 10 nuclear weapons whereas we have
thousands of nuclear weapons and in 1995
78 countries went to the International
Court of Justice pleading with the court
to declare nuclear weapons illegal and
inciting all kinds of international
covenants of our own country in a joint
statement of the Department of Defense
and Department of State argued that
having nuclear weapons threatening to
using them using them and using them
first does not violate st. Petersburg
Geneva Hague the conventions on the
ozone layer or any any of the phones and
yet that a court case which went on for
months was not even reported in the
United States showing that once you lose
the right of self-defense you also
continue you all so very much lose your
your own voice the other way in which
our kind of loss of civic stature shown
is in the fact that we've come to
believe that you can't eliminate them
and starting with our mayor and going
through to Allen we keep hearing that of
course we can eliminate them this isn't
a hugely difficult problem like solving
global warming you just dismantle them
and we know from the fact that there are
so many countries that have these
nuclear weapons-free treaties the whole
southern hemisphere is blanketed by
countries that have agreed to be nuclear
weapons-free this map shows the
countries in red that have nuclear
weapons and those that are nuclear
weapons-free and you can see that this
is very much a north-south problem
reports done in Scotland where they had
a recent referendum to separate from
England driven primarily by Scotland's
wish to get this for Trident submarines
out of the client rib out of the clyde
river the those people made a study of
how long it would take and that our own
military has set as an accurate study
showing that certain parts of it such as
the dismantling of the triggers can be
done in a matter of how
and other parts of it can take months
but it would take could all be done in
between two to four years but it would
take much more time for the United
States since we have a much greater size
Arsenal but it certainly is a very
doable thing and the fact that we so
much of our population believes that you
can't do anything is part of the
infantilization of the population that
has resulted from nuclear weapons so the
the specific National Covenant that I
talked about is our own constitution and
the way in which in with the invention
of nuclear weapons we've had to
eliminate both the the constitutional
requirement for a congressional
declaration of war and the actual
meaning of the Second Amendment the
right to bear arms whose true meaning is
to say no matter how much injuring power
you have whether it's zero or a vast
amount you have to distribute it equally
among your whole population in order to
hold it within a civil frame both these
provisions have been eliminated since
the start of the invention of atomic
weapons and just looking at the
congressional declaration of war and the
since the invention of atomic weapons we
have not even had an actual legitimate
congressional declaration of war even in
the case of conventional war and the
reason for that is presidents think look
as Nixon said if I can go into the next
room pick up a telephone and in 25
minutes 70 million people will be dead
that's an accurate statement that Nixon
made if presidents think that why do
they think they have to get permission
merely to invade Panama or Haiti so that
that the Senior bush in the first Gulf
War the said said I didn't have to get
some old goats permission in Congress in
order to kicks out of Hussein out of
Kuwait and his son the younger George
Bush said in his State of the Union
address in 2004 I pledge that I will
never
up and get a permission slip in order to
defend this country well that permission
slip is crucial because it means you are
not as a as a population permitted to
injure other populations until you have
tested it until you have put it through
to incredibly difficult procedural gates
and in a way that I can talk about at
some point where we have more time if
you look very closely at the at the the
deliberations for nuclear fort for
conventional war that we've had in this
country in the five cases where we've
had a declaration of war which is the
war of eighteen forty six 1812 the war
of eighteen forty six the
spanish-american war in 1898 in world
war one and World War two and you
compare it with the non deliberation
that occurs when our presidents have
contemplated using nuclear weapons and
that includes Eisenhower who
contemplated using them in 1954 Taiwan
Straits crisis Eisenhower again
contemplated using them in 1959 in
Berlin Kennedy we know from john from
robert mcnamara three times not once as
we think about in cuba three times came
within a hair's breadth of all-out
nuclear war that's quoting robert
mcnamara lyndon johnson considered using
them to prevent china from getting
nuclear weapons nixon said he considered
using them four times and considering
doesn't mean straight thought nixon for
example said sent 18 b-52s loaded with
nuclear weapons over russia towards
vietnam and the record stops there only
because whereas in the case of
congressional deliberation it's all open
and known to the public in the case of
presidential consideration of using
nuclear weapons it says allen said at
the end of his talk completely secret he
should be talking to alan roebuck we as
a population ought to be elgin and they
talked to Alan robock but the
the secrecy of it prevents that most
important and I'll just stop there is
the fact that in the presidential
deliberation about using nuclear weapons
that I look at into some detail in the
book thermonuclear monarchy there's no
dissent no one raises any kind of
testing of whether the proposition that
this population deserves this is true so
thank you
questions remain comments maybe it's not
good for him to criticize the host MIT
but my understanding is MIT still
operates Draper labs is that correct oh
it's not okay so i don't have to
criticize MIT but around 40 years ago
there was a referendum in cambridge to
ban classified research that would have
put Draper labs out of business the same
resolution passed overwhelmingly in
somerville but they have no classified
research right so it was defeated more
money was spent to defeat this
resolution per voter than any other in
the history of the United States and it
was defeated on civil libertarian
grounds we can't possibly stop
classified research so I'm wondering if
we could do that again get get this
stuff out of our area okay I'd like to
play the role of somebody who completely
disagrees with the people in this room
and I'd like to introduce another
metaphor to go with the one that you
used in your talk that of the United
States being mainlining a nuclear Jones
okay I know I've gotta have it but the
Russians of the pusher and I can't kick
the habit until we deal with the pusher
so I've got to stay on the habit there
are a lot of folks out there who think
that way let me give you a perfect
example I had a brief conversation with
one ben Carson about hair-trigger alert
and he said uh-uh we're not taking a
weapons off hair-trigger alert we need
it because of the Russians so the
question becomes how we deal with that
and how we deal with that mindset which
I submit prevails in our country it does
and just as there's a huge physical
architecture with thousands of weapons
and then a smaller portion of them but
it's still a large number on a
hair-trigger alert
Justin serves that physical architecture
there's a mental architecture in place
and that's one key component of the
mental architecture to think well of
course we'd want to get rid of it but
these other countries who are more
reckless than we are might not want to
get rid of it so we have to keep it
which is as Alan said a few moments ago
even to have it is is self suicide so
it's that is not actually an answer
furthermore it's slightly morally
preposterous for the country that
developed them is the only country to
have used them a country that is testing
them every day with its Sequoia computer
the one of the largest computers in the
world to talk about how ready they would
be if other countries were I think that
we should say we're ready and then ask
other countries to come along with us if
I could just jump in for one second the
argument that Ben Carson gave is
neglecting our mutual vulnerability
namely if the Russian system fails and
they fire we are dead and vice versa so
Elaine I'm going to change it I you've
heard me say this privately but I want
to say it publicly namely it's more than
nuclear weapons that undermines our
Constitution and its method of
governance and it's the whole national
security state and all the secrecy that
goes around it and this is a package and
it's been growing it's true that the
leading edge is the nuclear issue it
started during the Manhattan Project and
so forth but it's now graduated to the
big leagues right I agree with you and
the only thing that I would add is to
say that it that it starts with the
nuclear weapons and that it can end with
the nuclear weapons because by
disenfranchising the whole population
and making everybody feel
that if whether or not the country
considers takes on the most grave act
there is namely going to war it's just
something we should look at on TV rather
than we have anything to say about that
once that is gone that kind of Arsenal's
gone that brings about that civic injury
the people will regain the stature tip
that will make all kinds of other things
such as the security state impossible
the idea that that this country and its
papers belong to a certain small group
of men and the rest of us it's none of
our business is something that I think
is is will be short-lived I don't I
think that will end pretty quickly after
we get rid of nuclear weapons I just
like to say they view much this relative
to our relationship with Russia which is
the only other major party with nuclear
weapons and we have a very complex
relationship with Russia and apparently
if you've seen the picture with Obama
and Dmitri rather dislike of each other
as well and so unless we actually work
with Russia and actually somehow work
things out that it's not going to make
much difference at this point because
Russia has so many nuclear weapons but
so do we and so we are on two different
sides on a lot of world issues well we
certainly need to work with Russia and
many people would say let's do
unilateral disarmament regardless of
what other countries do I think it's
perfectly reasonable to say let's say
we're going to do nuclear disarmament
and get other countries to go along with
us and certainly at any point Russia has
not been in the rear in wanting to
disarm its population like the American
population doesn't want to live with the
daily threat of annihilation so you know
it's the same kind of situation where a
small number of people have brought
about an architecture that is you know
simply untenable and the you know I I
strongly believe that once once
countries begin other others will will
follow and it can even be a
of dismantling them Ophelia hi Elaine
thanks for coming I figured you were the
best person to answer this question how
do you think things like racism
xenophobia etc play into the
undemocratic nature of nuclear weapons
well fortunately there's a book that
documents bye bye Vincent and Tandy
called african-americans against the
bomb that shows the kind of incredible
part that's been played by African
Americans in this country in opposing
nuclear weapons starting at the moment
when the Hiroshima and Nagasaki bombs
went off and the rest of the country was
saying well I guess it's okay but
african-americans and papers and
everything was saying this is not okay
why did they say it's not okay well
according to many of the leaders who
explained this they they saw that it was
not okay both because they have a sense
that they know when their civil rights
have been violated they know that this
is a civil rights issue but also because
they knew it was a racist weapon at you
know it was it was used against other
races in Japan and and there's a strong
belief that that that that is the
predilection of the nuclear States to
use it against other races thank you I
wonder if you could put this in the
context historical context of compared
to the civil rights movement in the
1960s or Gandhi's movement in India
satyagraha is what we do we need a mass
movement of passive civil disobedience
to get the attention of the US
government I I think we do I mean
clearly we need everything we need the
scientists working as as we heard from
Allen and Ira but we also need the
population to come forward and stand
there and mass even if we can get as I
think through these legal provisions we
can get a court case that says our
current military policy is while the out
of line with our Constitution and I have
actually tried to work on such a case
and we got at least at least a judge to
say this might be something the Supreme
Court one day has to rule on e
but but even that legal decision cat
can't really work unless the population
remembers that it's their responsibility
to speak out about this and to come
forward and speak out about it hi Elaine
do you think that's diverting more
government funding to other government
programs like Social Security healthcare
NASA would be a better way to divert
funding away from the
military-industrial complex I mean I
absolutely think and this is something
Jonathan works on a lot and max works
out a lot I absolutely think that the
fact that we pay our taxes but have no
say on on on these weapons is is you
know a terrible terrible grave wrong the
I I've worked on nuclear weapons for
over 25 years and in that amount of time
i have paid so much tax money i have
actually contributed in nuclear weapons
and that's incredibly painful to me i
can work day and night i can write my
heart out I can stand and speak and
speak again but I'm putting thousands of
dollars into nuclear weapons how can
that be how can that be okay thinking of
that we will come back to that decision
yeah hi I'm good to see you again good
to see what is all how do I say um what
is the solution to the
military-industrial complex um you know
cuz people kind of are trapped in this
cycle of you know like do I you know
work for this company and then you know
how do i feed my family if I don't it
wasn't there like a very large like you
know educational initiative in the 60s
which you know like brought people into
like stem research for this purpose yeah
and and again this is something we'll
come back to but the employment does
have to be found for all those ppl
electric boat who are making the next
generation of ohio-class submarines the
12 new ohio-class submarines that are
gonna be made but it's not as though we
don't have other things that need to be
done
as Richard Rhodes points out in one of
his book the Society of Engineers has
shown that in all kinds of
infrastructure in the United States
schools bridges roads we're getting
grades of c- or d right now so it's not
as though there's not work to be done if
we stop making lethal weapons i just
wanted to make a comment about the
question about budgetary priorities you
know obviously there's a very strong
argument we made to cut the budget on
nuclear weapons because of all the other
important ways this money should be
spent but i think we have to understand
that people are not going to cut the
military budget as a lot the nuclear
budget as long as they have the mistaken
idea that these weapons protect us we've
seen this over and over again people
will spend whatever it takes to fit for
security and so the critical argument I
think that we need to make in addition
to how wasteful this isn't help pressing
the other needs are but we've got to get
people to understand that these weapons
do not in any way contribute to our
security and this is a very powerful
false notion it was it was the idea the
thing behind the comment that Ben
Carson's supposed to have made you know
that we need these because the Russians
have them and somehow are having these
protect us this is very very deep in our
in our psychology and for much of human
history having a bigger weapon actually
did make you somewhat safer now if
you're walking down a dark alley and
some guys coming at you and he's got a
bigger kind of stick and you get a
bigger stick you're a little bit safer
the problem is that nuclear weapons are
categorically qualitatively different as
Allen pointed out these are suicide
weapons and that's what we have to get
people to understand these weapons don't
protect us in fact they are the greatest
threat to our safety and security and
once we were able to convince some of
that and I think everything else will
flow much more easily
I just like to second what iris said you
can look at history and see whether
nuclear weapons were a deterrent did
nuclear weapons deter Argentina from
attacking nuclear-armed Britain in the
Malvinas war no the nuclear weapons
protect France from the recent terrorist
attacks no did they stop the attack on
Israel on the six-day war when Israel
had nuclear weapons did they win they
Vietnam War for us did they win the
Afghanistan war for the Russians or for
the Americans when the US was the only
nuclear country didn't stop the Soviets
from invading Eastern Europe so there's
many examples where they you can just
show that they haven't deterred anybody
so again they're more dangerous to have
than to not have there are only nine
countries in the world that have nuclear
weapons how did all the rest of the
world decide not to have them why they
decide not to have them what can we
learn from that some say one of the
pictures showed the countries which are
part of NATO are part of some Alliance
that they feel protected by the whole
southern hemisphere has no nuclear
weapons Costa Rica got rid of their army
and they're the most productive country
in Central America there are many
examples of why it would be beneficial
but like I recep people think a bigger
bomb is better but they're completely
different and that's what we have to get
into people's heads let's thank